early on in your rap career you write
about facing constant criticism and i
love this quote you say
a catholic school no matter how well
spoken or intelligent i was i was still
the black kid in winfield
no matter how up i was on the latest
music of fashion i was never quite black
i became one of the first hip-hop
artists who was considered safe enough
for white audiences but with black
audiences i was labeled soft because i
wasn't rapping about hardcore gangster
stuff
this racial dynamic is something that
has plagued me in various forms
throughout my entire life and i wanted
to ask you how have you navigated what
you call this racial dynamic
so
the elixir
for me
has been comedy
comedy crosses
all divides
if you learn how to make people
laugh
it's like um
it's the sugar for anything else that
you want to bring
to that person people are wide open
when they're laughing
right so
for me
throughout my career
the the
the bigger the laugh
i realized
the
less i was the black dude
[Music]
right
the the bigger the laugh
the less i was the soft dude
right laughter
trumps
everything
right and it's it's a magical
it's a magical energy that connects
people and that it
for a brief moment at least purifies the
poisons yes
and you're not in any way
marginalizing or minimizing overt racism
because you say every encounter i ever
had with overt racism
were with people i estimated to be weak
enemies at best
so overt racism although dangerous and
ever-present never made me feel inferior
i thought that was so interesting
i felt the same way same way so i was
raised to believe that you can encounter
any situation racist or otherwise hard
work education and god will topple any
and all obstacles and enemies and i
wonder how did that affect you moving
through the world of power as a black
man
so
it's funny tyrese called me one time he
was going through something
and
he was mad he had just left a meeting or
something like that
and
he said man what i got to do
to
walk into these meetings
and
have them not look at me
at just another walking in the office
and i said well you got to stop thinking
of yourself as walking in the office
right so
i don't i don't think of myself like
that
right so
because i don't think of myself like
that i'm not feeding that
in the person that i encounter
right but i just think i think it's it's
it's really important and i was blessed
as i talked about in the book my
encounters with overt racism
were neville with people i thought were
smart or strong had any power they
didn't have any power like even even
there were there were some like with
police interactions one of the times i
got called was from a cop
right
but
jl
beside me with my my manager
had a law degree
so he said thank you for that we're
going to head right to internal affairs
right so it's like
the the concept of of
intelligence hard work and god is what i
was raised with as above all things and
that you can fix it with that and you
can fix it with that
you